and the oscar goes
to nomad land
[Music]
it is the moment we've been waiting for
nomad land taking the top prize at the
academy awards
that plus glenn close twerking her way
into our hearts and some history makers
we are digging into all of that and so
much more including the biggest moments
of the night
as we recap the oscars on et live
hello everyone and welcome to et live's
oscars after show i'm denny director and
i'm cassie dolor
what a wild oscars night i never thought
i would hear you say twerking
at fiasco and glenn close yeah exactly
so much wildness to dive into we will
have some guests
joining us to break down everything in
detail but first
let's get into some recaps from the
night's biggest moments
starting with nomadland which won for
best picture of course
the top prize of the night starring
frances mcdormand
who also had an incredible night she
took home
a huge win for best actress for her role
as
fern in the film and also a huge
shock tonight after an awards season
streak
chadwick boseman didn't win best actor
that trophy instead went to 83 year old
anthony hopkins
for the father and twitter had a lot to
say about it we will get into all of
that you guys but first it was also a
big night for women
more importantly for some non-white
nominees right here chloe zhao
she won best director for nomad land
making her the first woman of color to
win the category and just the second
woman
ever cast to take home that trophy also
one of my favorite moments of the
evening
yoon won best supporting actress for her
role in minari making
history as the first south korean
actress to win the award at
73 years young okay i love it go
ladies what a fabulous night for the
women and uh speaking of we have
two of my favorite women joining us as
guest panelists tonight
et online's very own ash crossin and
carla renata
from thecurvyfilmcritic.com ladies thank
you so much
for spending your oscar sunday
with us let's kick things off with our
reaction to best picture as we mentioned
the big prize of the night went to nomad
land
ash i will start with you what are your
thoughts
to be honest i wasn't very surprised at
nomad land it was everything that came
after that that uh
was very surprising which we'll get into
it a little bit but i really did feel
like
it could have been any of the films it
really wouldn't have been a huge
surprise to me either way but i felt
like
after the independent spirit awards
especially like once we started getting
into the show
it became very clear that no this was
nomad land's
show so i wasn't very surprised to see
it take home that prize and what a night
for chloe zhao i'm just very
very excited and and proud of her like
what what a
night for her carla what was your
reaction to this win
i wasn't surprised like ashley that
chloe zhao would take home
the best director award for nomad land
making history being the second woman
ever to take home that award and being a
person of color i was uber excited about
that and i hope
that it changes the landscape in terms
of how hollywood looks
at women as directors and for once
i'm hoping that instead of talking about
women directors we just
it doesn't come along with a gender or a
label and nomadland has been winning
when winning has been winning best
picture all along so that was not a
surprise either
you know what was surprising is how they
managed to pull off the show you guys
because as we know of course in the era
of coven 19
it looked a lot different this year ash
what did you think of this more intimate
vibe
over at union station it gave me old
glamour old hollywood
i was kind of here for it what did you
think i gotta say i really did like the
union station of it all i thought the
look of the show was one of the best
it's been
and the feel like i mean i think year
after year we see people get to the best
moments of their lives
only to be like played off after like 30
seconds so i thought it was really
special to get these kinds of
intimate stories with these creators and
getting to hear their very personal
impactful stories on the other hand i do
think there was kind of a balance
missing here
because parts of the show felt like it
was like dragging on and on and on
especially at the beginning of the
telecast yes
i don't know it could have been the
order of the awards but i think honestly
the lack of the musical performances
within the telecast was a
huge mistake like that
we needed to break it up it's my biggest
criticism i mean they spoke like
throughout the show about how
movies should make you feel something
and nothing makes you feel more than
like the songs within the movies i just
felt like that
absence was felt tremendously i was also
missing some comedy there were some
funny moments but i think we needed like
the tina phase and the maya rudolphs to
present
well to your point and speaking of
absence noticeably missing was a
host carla i want to ask you do you
think that the oscars
needed a host or not this year obviously
we had previous oscar winners who would
kind of take turns
introducing different categories and
going off there but do you think that we
needed a host
i'm kind of split on my feelings about
that like i love having a host i loved
watching
when billy crystal or whoopi goldberg
throwing it back even further to when
bob hope used to do it
i love the feel of having a comedian
host the night
but i do also like the night of throwing
it back to the old hollywood days when
they used to have it like at the
hollywood athletic club
at the um you know what i mean yeah and
at the the hollywood roosevelt hotel
where there wasn't a host they just hit
hit it and quit it real quick i think
the very first oscars that they ever had
lasted less than 30 minutes
wow okay that was not this year
[Applause]
right exactly you guys you know most of
the presenters and the attendees were
there
at union station in la they had some
remote locations around the world so
everyone could participate
uh but more than anything you know there
were no zoom acceptance speeches
everyone
did did it live ash knowing that this
has been a very long award season
how do you feel like the oscars compared
to all the other virtual award shows
we've seen
this past year obviously i felt like the
production value was very high but i
have to be honest
i don't think i care if people are
zooming in in their pajamas or not like
it kind of brings this layer of humanity
to have like just all these hiccups like
the daniel kaluya one which what was
that the golden globes
i kind of love the moments like that and
i think with everyone being there with
all the covet protocols in place you're
right we didn't get a lot of the
interactions that we normally get those
funny moments the
the gaga leo elbowing incident anything
like that because
people just weren't getting close enough
to really have any of those moments so
i don't think i really cared if they
were in person or not i would have paid
big money to see anthony hopkins zoom in
or even make an appearance from london
in his pajamas obviously there are
many hours ahead and he was one of the
people who was noticeably
missing in any of those locations and it
was a big year for him he should have
been there because he took home the
award for best actor and
did not have a speech but we do have a
clip from his winning moment take a
listen
academy award for actor goes to
anthony hopkins the father
the academy congratulates anthony
hopkins
and accepts the oscar on his behalf
carla obviously going into the night
anthony hopkins was predicted to win but
also chadwick boseman was predicted to
win and i feel like
everyone was really hoping that he would
win and in fact
you know looking at the rundown of how
the oscars
was laid out this year normally best
picture is that last award and instead
it was flip-flopped to be
the best actor category announced last
so we all kind of thought okay this is
a big moment it's going to go to
chadwick and then it went to anthony
hopkins what did you make of this win
and that moment i'm really shocked
because as you guys mentioned earlier
chadwick boseman swept this awards
season
i think anthony hopkins only won once
and that was recently at the baftas
or the i think was at the baptist it
wasn't even the golden globes
and we expected him to win at the
baptist because that's in his own
backyard right
but everybody thought that chadwick
bozeman was going to get it this was the
last
opportunity to pay homage to someone
who's no longer here
and honor them even though he had swept
the whole entire award season so yeah
i was shocked and on a personal note you
know i'm a graduate of howard university
as was chad
boseman and kemp powers who won for
seoul so i was rooting for the hu
bicycle
but no shade to anthony hopkins 84 years
old
he is the oldest person to win the oscar
he hasn't won the oscars in silence of
the lambs
and you know at 83 years old if you
don't feel like getting on a plane and
coming to an acceptance award that's
your business
he doesn't have to be there you think
that so you know
you know obviously again this is kind of
this was a missed opportunity
for a big win for chadwick but what do
you think it was about anthony hopkins
role that
did it for the academy it was a tour
just like chad was chadwick's
performance in my reigns black bottom
anthony hopkins performance in the
father was a tour de force performance
and it struck a nerve
with people in the academy in a year
where there's been so much loss
due to covet 19. you know and having to
deal with
in the beginning of the pandemic a lot
of people that were passing away were
people that were in nursing homes
and a lot of those people in those
nursing home facilities were people that
had dementia
and or alzheimer's full-blown
alzheimer's so i think it struck a nerve
with people who are caring for elderly
parents
had an elderly parent that may have
passed from covet under those
circumstances
it's an emo it hit in an emotional way
that ma rainey's black bottom and
chadwick bozeman's performance didn't
hit
i was hoping for a tie maybe you know i
was all about the ties but
i can understand why people voted for
anthony hopkins it's anthony hopkins
he's
wonderful everything that he does is
social media sharing the same sentiment
that you just said right there because
you did raise a really valid point
uh or that past disorder but no um
people people uh mention what you guys
mentioned about
uh them flip-flopping the awards and
putting best actor at the end because i
think people did think that chad would
both they were going to have a moment
with chad with bozeman
and when that didn't happen it just felt
kind of awkward it's like oh is that how
we're going to end the oscars
so a lot of people on twitter are
talking about that and then some people
are saying what i just said
that anthony hopkins performance is a
tour de force he's 83 years old
and you know he's the oldest person ever
to win the oscar
which is you know it's a really great
thing because it shows that
ageism doesn't go away just because
you're 83 and you're nominated for
oscar there's some there's also
something really beautiful to be said
about that
but yeah folk on twitter they upset they
they are they are visibly
upset that chadwick boseman didn't win
because i think everybody
was hoping and leading up to it you know
that that's what was going to happen so
when
it didn't happen it was disappointing it
was disappointing for me i'm not going
to lie but
i respect that um anthony hopkins work
was honored
exactly and a huge congratulations to
anthony hopkins who might be
uh very well in his rem sleep right now
over in
the uk carla thank you so much for your
insight stick around we have so much
more
to break down with you later in the show
absolutely
let's switch gears to what i think was
another shocker of the night
best actress so a lot of the nominees in
this category were poised to make
history
but of course the trophy actually went
to francis mcdormand let's take a look
the oscar for best actress goes to
francis mcdormand
[Music]
[Applause]
i have no words my voice is in my sword
we know the sword is our work
and i like work thank you for knowing
that
and thanks for this well if the sword's
also an
oscar you can add three of them to
francis mcdormand's
long list of achievements but let's
bring in our girl ash crosston ash
because i was telling you that
i felt like this was the category to
watch leading up to tonight because
it could go anywhere you know and to
anyone based on like the
uh award season this past year were you
surprised it ended up going to francis
though
i was surprised i feel like the
conversation throughout the last few
weeks felt like we were really
circling a viola davis win early on in
the night especially like my radius
black bottom was getting a lot of love
but as the night went on it just became
no madland's night and i think to what
carla was saying
the flipping of the categories and the
with like the way they the the run of
show being different
it just felt like we were going towards
this very historic
night and it i don't want it to take
away from
francis mcdormand's performance or
anthony hopkins performance because
they're both incredible
but it just felt like we were leading to
this like really big moment at the end
of the show that we just kind of didn't
get
so it felt like we were just ended on
kind of a downbeat to your point like we
did get a lot of love spread throughout
the awards season like viola on the sag
award andre day won the golden globe
uh carrie mulligan won the critics
choice independent spirit award
it it did feel like the love was spread
throughout the season that it could have
really been any of them but i was
thinking it was going to be viola
maybe carrie i honestly did not expect
francis mcdormand
it's hard to compare performances
because all five nominees gave such
point yet but also different
performances what do you think
francis mcdormand by the way this is her
third best actress
win do you feel like they honored maybe
her legacy or was there something about
this performance in no man that you
think really struck a chord with the
academy
you know you have to remember in this
movie francis mcdormand
is one of there's there's another actor
in the movie but she's basically the
only actor in the movie she's
acting against people that are playing
as themselves who are real nomads who
chloe gell i mean just hats off to her
this is why she won the best director
because she got these people to just
i you would never even know but i think
francis's performance was really great
and really special for that reason she
brought a lot out of the people she was
acting across
it was a really really beautiful film
and frances mcdorman is incredible
we know she's incredible you know she
didn't get here for no reason you know
it just it just was kind of a surprise
and it was also so method because what
we know about the making of this film i
mean she really traveled in that van
with chloe
while they were making movies so she
completely transformed into the role so
much in fact that i felt like i was
watching her documentary i was like is
this fiction
uh but you know it was a classic francis
mcdormand performance and of course she
was
rewarded for it in kind ash crosston
stick around we have more with you
you're also going to talk about some
fashion who knew
love to see you thank you